paciente tras paciente este doctor de
cuidados intensivos ve como su unidad
alcanza su tope de capacidad en este
hospital al norte de parís están
llegando más personas enfermas de las
que son dadas de alta
tuvimos que abrir 8 camas extra para
cuidados intensivos de nuestros 26 camas
y 20 son para pacientes con
todas las ucis de la región de parís se
están acercando al punto de saturación y
esto podría ser sólo el comienzo las
proyecciones de los hospitales públicos
de la región están alertando de un
empeoramiento en las próximas semanas en
torno a 1500 pacientes kobe se
encuentran en estos momentos en cuidados
intensivos solamente en la región con
ello el país superó la barrera de los
5.000 pacientes uci una cifra que se
sitúa por encima del pico alcanzado
durante la segunda ola de mediados de
noviembre
este profesor afirma que el tiempo de
espera se acabó y se necesita de manera
inmediata un confinamiento estricto
sí sí instauramos un confinamiento
estricto necesitamos una campaña seria
de concienciación lo primero es que esto
no durará meses sino semanas si nos
unimos y empujamos todos juntos lo
superaremos
woods a clarín ya los funcionarios de
hospitales han basado sus proyecciones
en una perspectiva pesimista creen que
el confinamiento parcial actual tendrá
poco efecto el presidente francés
emmanuel macon hizo lo que muchos
consideran una apuesta arriesgada al
ignorar la recomendación de su consejo
científico y no imponer un confinamiento
estricto en enero citando la salud
mental de los estudiantes y la maltrecha
economía del país la llegada de nuevas y
más contagiosas variantes del virus ha
subido a las apuestas